[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين
التي كانت اليوم على موعد
[موسيقى]
ادي صور مباشره من تل ابيب التي تشهد
مظاهرات من احتجاجيه ضد حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو رفضا لخطه تغيير النظام القضائي
ولتغير القانون
[موسيقى]
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
تونس في الذكرى الثانيه عشر للثورتها
واقعوا ازمه المركبه واسئله تتزايد
احتجاجات رافضه للمسار السياسي ومطالب
بتغيير الجزري رئيس جبهه الخلاص يقول
للجزيره انه لا خروج من الازمه دون قياده
جديده ويدعوا لوحده سياسيه وفي رده على
موجه الرفض سعيد يصف المشهد بحاله حرب مع
ما وصفهم بالخونه والعملاء الاتحاد الشغل
يقول الا ان هذا البلاد مرهون بخيار ثالث
لا بد
مع استمرار التحضيرات من هجمات الصاروخيه
الروسيه واسعه النطاق مرافق البنيه
التحتيه ومنشات الطاقه الاوكرانيه تتعرض
لموجه قصف عنيفه
للقدرات القتاليه على الارض الدبابات
والمدرعات محور دعم الغربي
بينها دبابات ليوبار
ازمه تتصاعد بين لندن وتهران ايران تستدعي
السفير البريطاني احتجاجا على ما وصفتها
بالافعال المهدده للامن القومي
ولندن تستنكر اعدام مساعد وزير الدفاع
السابق علي رضا اكبر الذي يحمل الجنسيه
البريطانيه بتهمه التجسس وتعلن سحب سفيرها
بنت طهران مؤقته
هي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد نقشنا على
منصتنا الرقميه الوضع في تونس مع ذكر
الثانيه عشر
لثورتها وما تمر به من الازمات مركبه دعت
جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه للتضامن حول هدف
واحد هو رحيل رئيس الصعيد الاتحاد الشغل
دعى للاستعداد لما سماها معركه وطنيه
لانقاذ البلاد لكن هذه المعركه يراها
الرئيس قيس سعيد في مكان اخر حيث قال ان
البلاد في حاله حرب مع ما وصفهم الخونه
والعملاء والاستطاع ارائكم بهذا بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد فرحنا عليكم السؤال الثالث
حدثنا 10 عاما على الثوره التونسيه ما
توقعكم لمسار الاحداث في تونس
وهنالك 24% من المصوتين قالوا انها تتوقع
تواصل حاله الانسداد والجنود بينما صوت
13% لصالح حدوثه توافق سياسي على حل في
حين
63% لصالح خياري تصاعدي الاحتجاجات
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات من
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
الرمز كيو ار الظاهر الان على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصه الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات في تونس اذا هي جزء من سجال
سياسيين واسع وحائط الزمير حافظ مربح
ارافق المشهد في الارض ونقل الى صوره
التجذبات والمطالب في الشارع التونسيه وما
حدث فيه اليوم
لم يصمد الحاجز الامني المضرب على هؤلاء
المحتجين كثيرا بعد محاولات منعهم وعدم
الترخيص ببعضهم بالتظاهر فتوجه الى شارع
الحبيب بورقيبه امتزجت هنا التيارات
السياسيه على اختلاف مشاردها وتنوعت
الشعارات المرفوعه لكن معارضه السلطه
القائمه وحدتها
يمدد البعض بما يصفونه من حصارها مش
الحريه في البلاد وبما يعتبرونه قمعا
للمواطنين والناشطين السياسيين على حد
سواء
الازمه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه الراهنه
كانت حاضره بكثافه في المظاهرات فاحتج
المشاركون على ترد الوضع المعيشي للناس
وغلاء الاسعار وهي ببعض السلع عن الاسواق
الشعبوي يا اخي جوعت الشعب التونسي الشعب
التونسي توه على الحاضر كلها عبيد تجري
على باكو حليب ما فهميش تجري على كيلو سكر
ما فميش ينزل ال ال ال ال
الرئيسي تعدل للحوار ويتعدى ويتكلم الناس
الاعتراف لكل السياسيه وكل شيء ويلقى حل
للشعب هنا عبر المتظاهرون عن غضبهم ايضا
مما اعتبروه حكما فرديا للرئيس قيس سعيد
واتهموه بالفشل في تفسير البلاد فيما دعا
البعض الى توحيد جهود معارضه لدفع سعيد
الى الرحيل
استنى خلاص تونس سيتحقق حينما ينفذ
اخواننا
الحجابات الصغيره ويرتقون الى المرحله الى
مستحقات المرحله وهي رحيل عيسى سعيد
اذا ورقم اختلاف المرجعيات السياسيه
لهؤلاء المحتجين فان اغلبهم دعى الى اسقاط
حكم قيس سعيد والبحث عن حلول سريعه لازمات
يقولون انها باتت تهدد البلاد في الجهه
المقابله يبدو سعيد ماضيا في مساره غير
عابئ بالمعارضه ولا بمطالب طيف واسع من
التونسي ويتتهم معارضيه للخيانه والعمل
عملاء
تحقيق اراده الشعب في استرجاع امل الاموال
الشعب بينما تبقى الهوت واسعه الرئيسي
ومعارضيه تعاند تونس ازمه اقتصاديه
واجتماعيه عميقه يخشى كثير من التونسيين
تداعيتها على البلاد حفظ مربح الجزيره
تونس
وفي اي مقابله مع الجزيره قال رئيس جبهه
الخلاص الوطنيه التونسيه احمد نجيب الشابي
من المعارضه التونسيه حققت بمظاهرات اليوم
نقلت النوعيه باتجاه توحيد صفوفها رغم
اختلافاتها في تقييم الماضي
وحده المعارضه تحققت بدرجه دنيا لكنها نقل
نوعيه بنسبه لما كان عليه الامر في السابق
المعارضه التونسيه يقسمها الماضي هي تتفق
في التشخيص وتتفق في الحل ولكن تختلف حول
تقييم الماضي
وهذا هو الذي اعاقه توحده اليوم ولاول مره
التقى الطيف السياسي على اختلاف الوانه
واتجاهاته في شارع الثوره شارع الرئيس
بورقيبه وهذا لم تكن مظاهره موحده لكن
كانت عده مظاهرات في نفس الوقت في نفس
الشارع ومن اجل نفس الهدف
اقر الشب بحاله الانقسام بين القوه
السياسيه والمنظمات المدنيه وقال تعليقا
على المبادرات التي اطلقها الاتحاد
التونسي للشغل من اجل الحوار قال انها
مبادره لانقاذ النظام وان الاتحاد يعطي
فرصه للرئيس قيس سعيد الذي لا يحاور احدا
وفق تعبير
الاتحاد الشغل يقول يعني يقول بان له
مبادره لانقاذ تونس فالحقيقه حينما
الانسان يتفحصها يرى انها مبادره لانقاذ
النظام لانه يقول ان مبادرته سيطره على
قيس سعيد قيس سعيد بعد
يعني نعزل تماما في الداخل والخارج ورفع
عنه الشعب
يعطي اتحاد الشغل لهذا النظام فرصه
والجميع يعلم بالنقي السعيد لا يحاور احد
علينا في الاستوديو لطفي حجه مدير مكتب
الجزيره في تونس مظاهرات اليوم وصلت الى
شارع الحبيب بورقيبه رغم اييي
مخالفه ذلك لتعليمات الامنيه هل هنالك
مشهد مختلف اليوم ام هو استمرار للمشهد
السابق ولا يختلف عنه كثيرا هو يختلف
نسبيا عن المشهد السابق باعتبار انه اليوم
لاول مره اطياف من المعارضه المختلفه مع
بعضها البعض تتظاهر في نفس الشارع وكذلك
انضمت اليها همم مجموعه من الجمعيات
الحقيقيه صحيح ان هناك حواجز امنيه ربما
منعت الوصول واختلاط في ما بينهم لكن هناك
دلاله همم رمزيه ودلاله قويه لان الجميع
يتفقوا على نفس المطالب صحيح ان هناك عواق
يعتبرها الكثير انها من العواق الاساسيه
امام عمل المعارضه وهذا الانقسام هذا
التغريب الجوانب بالله الجيولوجيه احيانا
على المطالبه السياسيه الاساسيه لكن اليوم
وجود هذه لاط مختلفه في الشارع انا حبيب
برجيه وان في اماكن مختلفه من هذا الشارع
يبينوا ان هناك قناعه واحده على همم
محدوديه السلطه في تقديم مجموعه من
المبادرات لان المرحله التي سبقت هذه كانت
فيها مجموعه من المطالب الجميع كانوا
يطالبون السلطه بفتح حوار وطني كانوا
يطالبون السلطه بتقديمه همم مقترحات عمليه
وجديه وواضحه لحل الازمه الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه والاتحاد مثلا من بين مطالبه
كانوا يطالب السلطه ان تكون واضحه فيما
قدمته لصندوق النقد الدولي كل هذا لم يقع
لم تستجب بالسلطه مما طيب قرب هذه
المجموعات من بعضها البعض يعني ربما
استمعت معنا الى ما قاله احمد نجيب الشاب
وهو معروف يعني منذ سنين طويله
بدبلوماسياته واختياري بكلماته لكن اليوم
وصف بشكل واضح وصريح مبادره اتحاد الشغل
بانها لانقاذ النظام وليست تونس كيف تقرا
ذلك هو هذا يعلق ال ااه القطيعه بين جبهه
خلاص والاتحاد العام التونسي لشغل ان هناك
مجلات للنقد سابقا وقياده الاتحاد تؤكد
انها لن تكون معادها في تقوم بدور الاحزاب
لكن اليوم كان واضحا وفعلا هو سقف هذين
المبادرتين يختلفوا تماما ففي الوقت التي
تطالب جبه همم الخلاص وكذلك حتى الاحزاب
الخمسه الاخرى الاحزاب الاجتماعي التي
تظهرت بدورها بنجيبه طالب وبرحيل ما تصفه
بالانقلاب ياتي دور هذه المبادله التي
اعلنها همم الاتحاد وهيئه المحامين
والرابطه يقولون انها ستعرض على رئيس
الجمهوريه هكذا قال عميد المحامين في
تصريح سابق لكن ستعرض على الجمهوريه في
الوقت الذي لم تتفاعل على سلطه الرسميه
ولم يتفاعل رئيس الجمهوريه مع هذه ال- اا
المبادره مما يجعل هذه المبادره في نوعا
ميناء المغزى ان لم تتفاعل معها سلطه قول
التبوي عام اتحاد الشغل بان ال- ال- همم
حيث استعيد هو المشكله في الواقعه نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا لطفي حجي مدير مكتب الجزيره في
تونس
المشهد التونسي بالتطوراته افرز مجموعه من
القوه والتحالفات ارتبطت التقاء او ارتبط
التقاء عناصرها بالموقف من الرئيس قيس
سعيد ومن مسار الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
2020 نتعرف على ابرز هذه المواقف في هذا
العرض ونعود لنقاشنا
لان دعم اجراءات قيس سعيد في البدايه
الطيف من الاحزاب والمنظمات الا انا ما
يمكن اعتباره جناح المولات حصلت بعد الوقت
حتى طالت انتقادته قيس سعيد وتوجهاته من
ابرز القوه التي دعمت سعيد حزب الشعب وحزب
البعث الاشتراكي هو حركه تونس الى الامام
لكنها انتقدته خصوصا بعد اصداره قانون
الانتخابيه خاصه بالانتخابات التشريعيه
اما في المعارضه فبرزت ائتلافات جمعت
احزاب وشخصيات بينها جبهه الخلاص الوطني
برئاسه احمد نجيب الشابي وتاسست في مايو
2022 تضم وعيدته كيانه سياسيه واعتبرت
اجراءات سعيد انقلاب على الشرعيه من ابرز
مكوناتها حركه النهضه التي تصدرت في
البرلمان السابق قبل حله بن سعيد اضافه
الى حزب قلب تونس وائتلاف الكرامه كانت
تضم حركه مواطنون ضد الانقلاب واحزاب
الاخرى والشخصيات مستقله ودعت سعيد
للتناحي والى انتخابات مبكرا تلف عليها
شخصيه قضائيه توافقيه كتله معارضه اخرى
وهي كتله الاحزاب الاجتماعيه الديمقراطيه
وشكلت خمسه منها اقتلافا هي التيار
الديمقراطي والحزب الجمهوري وحزب التكتل
وحزب العمال والقطب الديمقراطي تتحركوا
بموازاه حرك جبهه الخلاص وتختلف معها
لكنهما تلتقيان في مناهضه توجهات واجراءات
سعيد كما دعت لمقاطعه جماعيه للانتخابات
التشريعيه ووضع خريطه طريق لانقاذ تونس
الحزب الدستوري الحر وتراسه عبير موسى وهو
محسوب على نظام بن علي ويعرض الجميع بما
فيهم قيس سعيد حذرت رئيسته من الاعتراف
باي مؤسسه تنبثق عن سمته المسار غير
الشرعيه وما سر الديكتاتوريه بعيدا عن
الاحزاب السياسيه يعد اتحاد الشغل من اهم
القوى المجتمعيه الاتحاد ايضا اجراءات
الصعيد وسماها مساء تصحيحيا لكنه لاحقا
رفض المشاركه في الحوار السياسيه الذي دعا
له واعتبر الانتخابات التشريعيه بلا رائحه
ولا لون جمع بعض المنظمات والهيئات
الاجتماعيه لاعداد مبادره انقاذ ضمن خيار
ثالث واعلن قياديون فيه رفض اي حوار مع من
يعتبرون حركه الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
قلابا واصفا اياه بالمسؤولين عما سماه
عشريه الخراب يفترق المعارضون لقيس سعيد
بينما يدعو امن عام اتحاد الشغل لما سماه
معركه وطنيه بهدف انقاذ تونس مضيفا ان
هناك مجتمع المدنيه ومنظمه وطنيه تقول
للحاكم لا للعبه بالبلاد
من تونس رضا الحاج القاضي في جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه ومن تونس ايضا احمد همامي المتحدث
الرسمي باسم تحالف احرار وابدا برضا
بالحاج
وما قاله احمد نجيب الشابي من انه هنالك
اتجاها اكثر نحو التوحد بين المعارضه لكن
خطابه اتجاه اتحاد الشغل مختلف يقول ان
مبادرته هي مبادره لانقاذ النظام وليست
لانقاذ تونس كما يقول اتحاد الشغل لماذا
هو اليوم صحيح اليوم جبهه الخلاص نزلت الى
الشارع وكان
بحجم كبير وكان وقعها كبير على الراي
العام وكذلك ما هو جديد اليوم هو مشاركه
الشارع شارع الثوره بوجود مكونات اخرى
منها الاحساب الاحزاب الخماسي المكونه من
الاحزاب الاجتماعيه وكذلك من جمعيات
ومكونات من المجتمع المدني من قضاه من
المحامين فكان التواجد متنوع وهذه نقله
نوعيه تؤكد ان
اغلبيه
الشرع الاجتماعيه
ومكونات المجتمع المدني اليوم خرجت في
المعركه من اجل العوده للديمقراطيه رغم
اختلافاتها حول همم
حول تبني خارج طريق معينه هنالك خلافات
لكن اا بالنسبه للرجوع للديمقراطيه
بالنسبه لمقاومه الحكم الفردي بالنسبه
للفوضى في مؤسسات الدوله التي ادخلها قيس
سعيد هنالك اتفاق اما بالنسبه لموضوع
الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل فنحن نعتبر
ان كل مبادره هي ايجابيه ويمكن ان تساهم
في الخروج من الازمه الا ان
كمشي الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل وخصوصا
بعد القيادات المتحذبه داخل قياده الاتحاد
في اقصائي همم الاحزاب وفي
دمج المبادره تحت سقفي الانقلاب وتحت سقف
همم
يجعل هذه المبادره في اشكاليات همم
بالنسبه
لمستقبلها وبالنسبه لنجاح طيب
احمد همم همامي المتحدث الرسمي باسم تحالف
احرار الاتحاد التونسي للشغل يتحدث كما
قال همم نور الدين الطببوبي اليوم عن خيار
ثالث ما هو تصورك انت لمثل هذا الخيار هل
يوجد خيار ثالث وبين رحيل سعيد او بقاء
سعيد
شكرا
كالعاده يعني نحن نثمن عن العمل الاجتماعي
ولكن همم العمل السياسي الذي يقوم به
الطرب بشخصيه همم مرورا نحن تصورنا كان
واضح تصورنا ان همم
تونس ستمضي نقود من نحو برلمان الجديد
والخروج من الحاله الاستثنائيه الى الحاله
العاديه واكبر دليل الديمقراطيه بفعلها في
حقيقه امر الديمقراطيه ما رشاد ابناء
اليوم منذ فتره انه كل المواطنين من حقهم
التظاهر من حقهم التواجد في الشارع او
محكم ان يعاقبوا الديمقراطيه يعني تبنى
على المعارضه لكن للاسف فشل
همم لمكونات هذه المكونات التي عرضتها
العزيزه
10 مكملات اذا كانت الديمقراطيه تبنى على
المعارضه
من اذن الخونه والعملاء الذين لا يكفوا
الرئيس قيس سعيد عن الحديث عنهم هل هم
الذين خرجوا في الشارع اليوم
يه المطروحه امام القضاء اليوم
الملفات المطروح ضد وزراء سابقين وهناك
وزير في السجن هناك بطاقات جلب في عديد
وعديد الشخص
يات التي باعت نفطرين باعت ذمامها للاجنبي
عندما نسمع اليوم السيد المنصف المرزوقي
يدعو الجيش
[موسيقى]
ليست بخيانه من الوطن
النيابه العموميه باتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه في حق النص المرزوق ومن تقابل
نفسه انه نفسه ان يمس من الامن العام
الدكتور المرزوق يرد على هذه الاتهامات
لانه سيكون ضعيفا في فقره لاحقا في
البرنامج لكن حتى نفهم العشريه السوداء
يعني هل هي انتهت هل المشاكل العشريه
السوداء انتهت الرئيس قيس سعيد رئيس منذ
عام 2019 اليس هو جزء من العشريه السوداء
طبعا لم يكن لم يكن ولم يكن ولم يكن جزءا
من العشريه السوداء عندما اتخذ القرار
يعني 25 جويده باقات تلك المهزله السياسيه
المطروحه داخل ذلك البرلمان راينا من اين
فيه ذلك البرنامج الدماء
دسيه
قبل 25 جويليه مازن هل ما يحدث
حينما توصف المعارضه
بتوصف المعارضه بالخونه والعملاء ولا يفتح
حوار باب حوار مع اي احد هل هذا تعتبر ذلك
مهزله
معرض بالعملاء السمنه العملاء والخونه
لانه الرئيس
عارف والملفات موجوده على على الطاوله
القضاء وموجوده الان هناك العديد من
القضايا رفعت ضد من كانوا اجربوا في عشريه
سوداء وابشر التونسيين من هذا المكان
فتح داخل وزاره العدل بما يخص يعني
يعني القضاه المعذورين ملفاتهم اليوم امام
القضاء وربما سنشد في الايام القادمه
جلسات
لما
اااهيا هو العيد الثاني عشر للثوره خرجت
مظاهرات ثم عاد كل الى بيته ما الذي يمكن
ان يتغير في المستقبل تريدون الاطاحه بقيس
سعيد تريدونه ان يرحل كيف سرحل
هو صحيح اليوم همم
قمنا بمسيره البخمه وعدنا الى همم
لكن اليوم هنالك نقل نوعيه بعد ان نقله
النوعيه التي اثبتت ان قيس سعيد ليست له
شعبيه كما هو يقدمها
وذلك بمقاطعه الانتخابات وبمشاركه 8% او
10% او 11 في المياه وكانت سابقه لم
تشهدها تونس ولا حتى في اي بلد من العالم
اليوم كذلك اظهر الشارع ان جزءا كبير من
الشعب التونسي رافض لقيس سعيد واتفقوا على
مطالبته بالرحيل هذه نقله نوعيه اخرى
الازمه الاقتصاديه تشتد العزله الداخليه
تتعمق بالنسبه لقيس سعيد اليوم تقريبا
نفسيه كيف ستجعلون يرحل هذا هو السؤال
سياتي اليوم التي سيرحل وهذا اليوم ليس
ببعيد الازمه تتعمق الشارع همم
شيئا فشيئا همم
التقدم والا النزول الى الشارع بطريقه
سلميه هنالك اضرابات هنالك العديد من
المبادرات التي تضغط على عين هو من
الناحيه الاقتصاديه دوليا في حاله اختناق
من من جراح سياسيته
والاستبداد الذي اقامه اليوم هنالك مقاطعه
تقريبا من كل المؤسسات الماليه الدوليه
باعتبار ان تونس ليس فيها استقرار ليس
فيها حكومه كفئه ليس فيها رئيس يمكن ان
يلتزم لا يتوفر فيه شروط المسؤوليه التي
تجعله يوم في اتفاقيات معه مع المؤسسات
الماليه وبالتالي عمور هذا النظام القيس
سعيد معلوم ومحدد زمنيا شكرا جزيلا لك
احمد همم اشكر رضا بلحاج الخيذي في جبهه
الخلاص الوطني واشكر ايضا احمد همام
المتحدث باسم تحالف احرار
من الحديث عن تونس في الذكرى الثانيه عشر
ثالث
المشهد السياسي في البلاد المشهد سنناقشه
مع اول رئيس تونسي تولى السلطه بعد ثوره
[موسيقى]
الى الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا وموجه
هجمات جديده تستهدف البنيه التحتيه في
انحاء البلاد
اكثر من 20 صاروخا من بين اكثر من 30
صاروخا تم اطلاقها فوق اوكرانيا خلال
اليوم اضافه ان مرافق البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه تضررت بفعل ضربات الروسيه وكانت
السلطات الاوكرانيه
الروسيه تتضاربت مرافق البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه في مناطق ايه والريف
تطورات لافته في مجريات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا خلال الساعات الماضيه ميزتها
حاله استهداف متزامنه لمنشات البنيه
التحتيه الاوكرانيه فقد اعلنت الاداره
العسكريه فانه هجوم الروسيه
او صواريخ اس 300 استادف منشات كهرباء في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه مما ترى سكانها
للاحتماء بمترو الانفاق وحتى رئيس البلديه
السكان على البقاء في الملاجه على اثر ذلك
اعلنت شركه الكهرباء الاوكرانيه
سابقه وفرضت حالات قطع طارئه للتيار
الكهربائي في ثياب والمناطق المحيطه بها
وقالت الشركه ان عمالها يسابقون الزمن
لاصلاح الاضرار وفي مدينه الفيف غربا حذرت
السلطات من امكانيه انقطاع امدادات المياه
والكهرباء بعد ضربتين صاروقيتين على منشات
البنيه التحتيه
فقال عمده المدينه ان القوات الروسيه
تستهدفه المدينه باربعه صواريخ من طراز اس
300 وان القصف شامله البنيه التحتيه
للطاقه الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه الصناعيه
واعلن فرد قطع طارئ للتيار الكهربائي بعد
ضربتين على منشات حيويه
في جبهات اوكرانيا الشرقيه بوجه خاص اعلن
عدد من الحلفاءك في الغربيين
اعتزامهم تزويدها بمركبات قتاليه جديده
ودبابات
وصول الدفعه الاولى من تلك الاسلحه
الهجوميه خلال الشهر القادم او الاشهر
القادمه لكن تلك الخطوه ما زالت موضع
السجائر داخلي في بعض العواصم الغربيه كما
ان التساؤلات الثور حول قدرتها على تغيير
مسار الحرب
مرحله جديده اخيرا وعد البلد المبتلى
بالحرب بمركبات القتاليه المدرعه ودبابات
حديثه لا خلاف على حاجه اوكرانيا اليها مع
تكليف الروس ضغطهم على جبهتكال
بوصول الدفعه الاولى من ذاك العتاد الهجوم
الثقيل على الارجح خلال شهرين او ثلاثه
سيرتفع الدعم الغربي لكيف الى مستوى جديد
تعلن بريطانيا عزمها تزويده اوكرانيا
بدبابات قتاليه من طراز تشالنجر
62 طنا ومزوده بمدفع عيار 120 ملمتر قد
تزود الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا بعربات
القتاليه من طراز برادليه التي تزن سبعه
وعشرين ومزوده بمدفعه عيار 25 ملمترا
وسواريخ خارقه للدروع فرنسا سترسل مركبات
القتاليه مدرعه خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس
10 ار سي المزوده بمدفع من عيار 215 ملم
ويناقش المسؤولون في المانيا امداد كيف
بدبابات قتاليه ومدرعات من طراز ماردر
التي يبلغ عيار مدفعها الاوتوماتيكي 25
ملم
لا شيء محسوما بعد في عواصم غربيه علقت
بين الحماسه والحذر فباريس ووارسو مثلا
تضغطاني على برلين بحسب تقارير غربيه
لاقناعها بارسال الدبابات حديثه ثقيله من
طراز لا يطارد اثنان الى اوكرانيا
هناك داخلي ايضا في الدول الداعمه
لاوكرانيا حول جدوى ومحاذير نقل التسليح
الى مربع جديد من ذلك المناقشات الجاريه
في بريطانيا منذ اسابيع بشان تزويد
اوكرانيا بدبابات من طراز تشالنجر اثنان
ضلت الدول الغربيه للشهور تمتنع عن ارسال
الدبابات وعربات القتاليه المتطوره الى
الاوكرانيين خشيه اثاره غضب روسيا فماذا
تغير الان ربما تشيل خطوه بالرغبه في
تسريع استعاده اوكرانيا لاراضيها التي
باتت تحت سيطره الروس يرى خبراء ان
المركبات القتاليه ستساعد اوكرانيا في
استكشاف مواقع القوات الروسيه وكذا نقل
الجنود وضرب المركبات المدرعه الروسيه كما
انها توفر ميزه تكتيكيه كبيره لا سيما ان
كان الاوكرانيون يتطلعون الى اطلاقه هجوم
لاستعاده الاراضي هذا العام
لكن احدا لا يعتقد كما يبدو بان الاسلحه
الثقيله الجديده ستحقق التفوق او تحدد
بمفردها مسار الحرب والحرب يحذر الكرملين
من ان الخطط الغربيه لتزويد كيف باسلحه
اثقل هو ما سيطيل امدها بالنسبه
الاقدام على ذلك لا يحدث تغييرا ميدانيا
جذريا لمصلحه الاوكرانيين
[موسيقى]
بوابه لمزيد من التصعيد الايراني
البريطانيه هذا ممثله اعلان السلطات
القضائيه الايرانيه تنفيذ حكم الاعدام بحق
علي رضا اكبر نائب وزير الدفاع الايراني
السابق بتهمه التجسس لصالح الاستخبارات
البريطانيه وكانت استخباراته الايرانيه
اعلنت في وقت سابق ان اكبر كان يتجسس على
المراكز الحساسه والاستراتيجيه في ايران
صدفه الارز اكبر
ثلاث سنوات واعظمته ايران بعد لائحه اتهام
كانت ثقيله تفصل السلطه القضائيه التهام
وتقول انه كان يتجسس لصالح الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ويمدها بمعلومات عن الاماكن
الحساسه في ايران مسؤوليه الرجل في النظام
الايراني ربما تزيد اهميه المعلومات التي
نقلها كما تقول الاستخبارات فقد شغل اكبر
مناصب حساسه في وزاره الدفاع والقوه
المسلحه وهو على علاقه بامين مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني
فقد حملتها طهران مسؤوليه تتعيلتي ما تصفه
بتجديد احد مسؤولها السابقين وطلبتها
بتوضيح وهي تستدعي سفير بريطانيا
عند اي عمليات تجسس تفتح ملفات ما حدث في
ايران بعد اعتقال اكبر اغتيل العالم
النووي فخري زاد واستهدفت مقار نوويه لم
تربط ايران وبين اعتقاله وتلك الحوادث لكن
يبقى السؤال عن حجم المعلومات التي سربت
من ايران عبر جواسيسه الى جهه اجنبيه
قد يضلوا متواصلا ما دامت هناك ملفات
ساخنه بينهم لم تحسم حتى لحظه طهران
وفي رد فعل لندن قال وزير الخارجيه
البريطانيه جيمس كلوفرلين بلاده اخترعت
سفيرها من ايران مؤقتا في اعقاب اعدام
المواطن البريطاني الايراني علي رضا اكبر
واضاف كليفر لي ان لندن تبحث الاجراءات
الاخرى التي يمكن ان تتخذها ضد طهران واكد
انه من المهم ان يتم الادراك بان ردنا لا
يقتصر بالضروره على الاجراءات المعلنه
وكان وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه كليفر لقد
اعلن فرد عقوبات على النائب العام
الايراني وبدوره عبر الرئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي هناك عن صدمته لاعدام علي
رضا اكبر ووصف في تغريده لاعدام بانه عمل
قاسم وجبان نفذه نظام همجي لا يحترم حقوق
الانسان لشعبه على حقوله
اعراب المبعوث الامريكي الى ايران روبرت
مالي عن استيائه لاعدام المواطن البريطاني
من اصل نيرانيه علي رضا اكبر وقال في
تغريده انه شعر بالفزع عندما علم بالخبر
وشدد على ضروره وضع حد لما وصفها
بالاعتقالات الجائره والاعترافات القسريه
والمحاكمات السوريه والاعدامات ذات
الدوافع السياسيه في ايران
انضم الينا من طهران محمد مهدي شريعه مدار
المستشار السياسي والدبلوماسيه السابق ومن
لندن
وزير الدوله البريطاني الاسبق وابدا بك
سيد همم
وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني يتحدث عن دوافع سياسيه في اعدام
علي رضا اكبر همم هل المقصود دوافع سياسيه
خارجيه ام ايضا داخليه
شيماء وزير الخارجيه البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
الوزير يتحدث عن الدوافع الداخليه المحليه
في ايران والنظام الايراني
الى الخطاب المعتمد بالاضافه الى استدعاء
السفير وايضا هناك دعم من قبل الدول
الجاره للمملكه المتحده نحن نتحدث عن
استوقفك للحظه سيد بار قلت انه دوافع
داخليه سياسيه داخلي سياسيه داخليه ما هي
هذه في رايك
اعتقد ان العالم يمكنه ان يرى ان النظام
في طهران يعاني من سلسله من الصعوبات حيث
انه يواجه مظاهرات نراها ونحن نعرف ان
النظام الايراني لديه عناصر مختلفه تبحث
عن امور مختلفه وطبعا هذا يتاثر بمستقبل
مفاوضات النوويه ولكن ايضا هناك مسائل
داخليه تؤثر على العالم السياسي في ايران
هذه امور ايرانيه يمكن ان نراها نحن من
الخارج ولكن المهم هو اننا نتحدث عن عمليه
اعدام غير عادله حيث ان السيد كان طبعا قد
شرح في فيديو في هذا الاسبوع وتحدث عن همم
اكثر من 3000 ساعه من التع طيب
لاستدراجه
الادلائه بمعلومات وعلى هذا الاساس قالت
المملكه المتحده ان عمليه الاعدام يجب ان
لا تحصل وهذا ما تشاركته سلسله من الدول
ودانت هذا الفعل
استاذ محمد مهدي شريعه مدار المستشار
السياسي ودبلوماسي السابق يعني هل كان
يعني القانون لا ينص على اي خيارات اخرى
في مساله اكبر سوق الاعدام
نعم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولضيفك وولي مشاهدي قناه الجزيره اولا اود
ان اقول ان الموضوع لا علاقه له بالسياسه
لا بالشان الداخلي ولا بالعلاقات
الايرانيه الغربيه ولا بالملف النووي ولا
بالحرب الجاريه على اوكرانيا وكل ما يقال
وما قاله ضيفك لا علاقه له بالموضوع الرجل
القي القبض عليه قبل ثلاث سنوات ليس لم
يلقى القبض عليه خلال الاشهر الاخيره حيث
لنربط لنستطيع ان نربط هذا الموضوع همم
الاحداث الجاريه خلال الاشهر الاخيره في
ايران تم التحقيق معه وبكل ارتياح واعترف
بشكل واضح وشفاف بكل همم استدراجه للعلاقه
مع ال همم
المخابرات البريطانيه لكن في الاخير طبعا
نعم حينما شاهد كان يتصور انه سيعفى او س-
تخفف عقوبه بالنسبه له حينما علم ان الامر
يختلف همم نعم اعلن انه يعني تعرض الى ما
لكن في الواقع كل التسجيلات الموجوده له
تدل على انه يتكلم بكل ارتياح
بشريعه
لمسؤولين كثيره
اصلا يعني عقليا لا نقبل ان يكون نعم نعم
ماذا
تبعد البعد السياسي الداخلي دعك من الخارج
لكن على اي اساس تستعد البعد السياسي
الداخلي وهنا اليك دائما همم لعبه سياسيه
موجوده في كل بلد وايران ليستثناء
اشرت الى ذلك اولا حينما يربط الموضوع
بالاحداث الاخيره وهو القي القبض عليه قبل
ثلاث سنوات هذا هذا هو الدليل الاول
ثانيا هو كان مقرب ل اعلى السلطات في
البلد وبالمناسبه كانت له علاقه مع كلا ال
الطرفين او كلا الجناحين الحاكمين في
ايران يعني حتى لا يمكن ان نقول عقليا لا
يمكن ان يقبل اصلا دعكه من من كل
المعلومات الموجوده حتى من ناحيه التحليل
السياسي لا يمكن القول انه مثلا يعني ربما
كان ضحيه صراعات في الداخل ابدا كان على
علاقه مع كل الاطراف لذلك هو ارتكب كما
اعترف بذلك وبكل وضوح
ارتكب هذه الجريمه الجريمه بالاجابه على
سؤالك الاول هل كان من الممكن ان تكون
عقوبه اخرى غير الاعدام لا القانون
الايرانيه نصف على ان المنخرطين في
المؤسسات العسكريه والامنيه والذين يقدمون
معلومات على مستوى معين الى بحيث يعني
يشكل خطرا على الامن القومي عقوبتهم تصل
الى حد المحاربه والمحاربه عقوبتها
الاعدام بمعنى ان التجسس العادي ربما يكون
تكون عقوبته السجن طبعا لمدايات مختلفه
لمده مختلفه لكن اذا كان الشخص منخرطا في
المؤسسات العسكريه وقدم معلومات هامه تمس
بالامن القومي فهذا يعتبر من يعني
جرمته تعتبر محاربه والمحاربه عقوبتها
الاعداء
وزير الخارجيه تحدث عن اجراءات اخرى غير
معلمه
كيف ستكون
ام دي فرصه ثانيه
[موسيقى]
بالاعمال الايرانيه لكي يعرب عن ادانه
الحكومه البريطانيه بالاضافه الى ذلك
الحكومه البريطانيه وزاره الخارجيه على
وجه الخصوص لديها اجراءات اخرى لا اعرفها
انا لا امثل الحكومه لذلك لا اعرف ما هي
الاجراءات ولكن اعتقد ان المملكه المتحده
سوف تخاطب دول اخرى لربما ليتم التعاون في
هذا السياق لانه من الواضح ان الدول
الاخرى تتشاطر وبريطانيا نفس مشاعر الغضب
تجاهها الاعدام الذي جرى بحقه السيد اكبر
لكن المملكه المتحده قد لك تكون قد اتخذت
القرار بشان كل هذه الاجراءات باشكرك
وشكرا جزيلا من لندن
وزير الدوله البريطانيه الاسبق ومن طهاره
محمد مهدي شريعه مدار المستشار السياسي
والدبلوماسي السابع
فظهر الاف الاسرائيليين في تل ابيب والقدس
الغربيه وحيف ضد حكومه السادسه تعبيرا عن
معارضتهم لخطتها الراميه لتغيير النظام
القضائي والقانون ولو حل المتظاهرون
بالعلم الاسرائيليه ورده تعتبر تغيير
النظام القضائيا على الديمقراطيا ويخسر
المتظاهرون المنتمون لحركات واحزاب
اليسريه ومن وسط الخريطه السياسيه الحزبيه
من ان التواريخ فتى الحاكمه تقوموا
بينقلاب العالم النظام القضائي وانها تسعى
انهاء اسرائيل كدوله ديمقراطيه وفقعه
شعاراتهم
قتلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شابين
فلسطينيين باطلاق الرصاصي على سياره كما
يستقلانها قرب بلده الجبهه جنوب جنين كما
استشهد شاب ثالث متاثرا بجروح اصيب بها
قبل ايام في قريه كفردان غربه جنين وقد
شيع الفلسطينيون في جنين جثامين الشهداء
الثلاثه وسطه تافات تردد بجرائم جيش
الاحتلال والمستوطنين وعم ادراهم شامل
محافظه جنين حدادا على الشهداء
هذا ما تبقى من المركبه التي كان يستقلها
الشهيدان عز الدين حمامره وامجد خليليه في
نهايه ملاحقه قوات الاحتلال لهم في بلده
جبع جنوبيه جنين الجيش الاسرائيلي قال ان
احدى دورياته تعرضت لاطلاق نار من سياره
مسرعه قرب مدخل البلده فطاردتها واطلقت
النار على من بداخلها
من الحزن خيمت على اهالي الشهداء خاصه
والفلسطينيين عامه في جنين شهود عيان
اكدوا ان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعدم من كانوا
بداخل السياره بعد توقفها
السياره مكمله شوي اييه اجوا جيش حاوطوا
السيارات ونزلوا من الجيبات وصفوهم يعني
بكل بالسياره اعدام يعني اعدموهم اعدام
[تصفيق]
وفي موكب التشييع تعالت الهتافات المطالبه
بالثار لحمام وخليليه الى جانب يزن
الجعبري الذي استشهد متاثرا بجروح اصيب
بها مطلع الشهر الجاري
حركه الجهاد التي ينتمي اليها الشهيدان
دعت الى تعزيز الوحده الوطنيه في مواجهه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
نستطيع مواجهه هذا العدو بمزيد من الصبر
والثبات ومزيد من تعزيز الوحده الوطنيه
على الارض والميدان على اساس البندقيه نحن
مختلفون سياسيين ولكن نحن كل شعبنا وكواهم
متفقين على خيار الشهداء والجرحى والاسرار
وقد عم الاضراب العام مدينه جنين حدادا
على ارواح الشهداء ففي مختلف انحاء الضفه
الغربيه استشهد عدد من الفلسطينيين منذ
بدايه هذا العام كان نصيب محافظه جنين
وحدها سبعه شهداء كما لم يستلم الاطفال من
الاستهداف الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحام قوات
الاحتلال للمدن والبلدات الفلسطينيه في
الضفه الغربيه يقول الفلسطينيون ان عمليات
الاغتيال الاسرائيليه والتي كان اخرها
اغتيال حمام رواد خليليه في جنين ستواصل
طالما استمرت عمليات الاقتحام والمداهماته
لمدونهم وقراهم خاصه ان هذه العمليات جاءت
عاقبه تسلم حكومه هديه جديده بمقاليد
الحكم حكومه توصف بانها الاكثر تطرفا في
تاريخ اسرائيل
سمير ابو شماله الجزيره جنين فلسطين
[موسيقى]
اليوم الى شارع الحبيب بورقيبه مجددا تونس
ما بين عام 2011 عام 2023 في العرض الثالث
كان ذاك يوما التقى الجمع على كلمه واحده
شارع واحد احتضن كل المشارب الفكريه
والسياسيه والروافد القطاعيه ووحدهم خلف
كلمه سواء
شغل حريه كرامه وطنيه الحبيب بورقيبه ليس
مجرد معلم رئيسيين يتوسط قلب العاصمه تونس
بل هو الشارع الرمز والثقل السياسي
والامني وفيه كانت الدروه ثوره دعت للقطع
مع ميراث الفساد والاستبداد وادت لسقوط
الرئيس السابق بن علي واشرعت الباب لامل
بتغيير سياسي واجتماعيا واقتصادي لكن
الامس لم يكن شبيها بغده فبعد 12 عاما من
الثوره عاد الجمع شتاء خمسه تجمعات
احتجاجيه في مناطق متفرقه جغرافيا تفصلهم
بضعه امتار فقط اما مطلبي
السياسيه في تونس متفقه نظاريا على ضروره
التصدي اللي ما تسميه المسار الاحادي الذي
فرضه الرئيس قيس سعيد منذ الخامس والعشرين
مليون يورو عام 2020 لكنها تعجز حتى
اللحظه عن التوصل الى مبادره سياسيه
الجامعه وبديل احد لتجاوز الاسماء فالمشهد
متشرد من بين من يرى الاصلاح من داخل
المنظومه الحاليه ممكنه واخر يعتبره
مستحيله وثالثا يرى في نفسه بديلا دون
سواه ورابع يعتبر نظام سعيد نتيجه وما
الان طبيعيه لاخفاقات احزاب وحكام ما بعد
الثوره ومنهم من يرفض الاخر فكرالجيولوجيا
وبينهم من يحمل طيفا منهم مسؤوليه فقدان
الشعب الثقه في الاحزاب السياسيه وفي
الاثناء واقعوا اجتماع المتردد وارقام
متدهوره واقتصاد منكمش واسعار ملتهبه تذكر
ان الثوره ثوره شارع وشعب ومجتمع قبل ان
تكون لساسه واحزاب تاكل رصيدها وهوت شعبيه
وعلى جدتي الخلافات والشقاقات يحاول اتحاد
الشغل من ساحه المجتمع المدني اي يقف موقف
الحياد من الجميع سلطه ومعارضه وان يقود
مبادره انقاذ لكنه ليس بمعزل هو خرا عن
التقييمات اللي يعتبره طيف واسع من القوى
السياسيه شريكا ومساهما بنجاحات واخفاقات
ما بعد الثوره وبين هذا وذاك شعب يركب
تحرك سياسيا يخرجه من ازمته ومنجزه
اقتصاديا يضمن نقوطه واسئله عن ما تبقى من
مطالب ثورته
اول رئيس لتونس ما بعد الثوره والذي شغل
هذا المنصب في احدى اهم مراحل الانتقال
الديمقراطيه واكثرها دقه دكتور منتصف
المرزوقي اهلا وسهلا بك همم اليوم يمر احد
عشر عاما بالتمام والكمال على همم هروب بن
علي وانتصار الثوره التونسيه اليوم
كان متوقعا في هذا الوقت في وقت ايه 2011
هل كان المشهد اليوم كان لاحد في 2011 ان
يتصوره
طبعا يعني هناك قراءه ثانيه يمكن قراءه
النصف الفارغ من الكاس وهو انه فعلا يعني
بعد اكثر من 10 سنوات
وثورتنا لن تستطيع ان تحقق ما جاءت من
اجله لكن ايضا قراءه النص الكاس وهو انه
يعني اراده الشعب لم تقهر والى حد الان
هذا الشعب ما زال يطالب بحقوقه في
الديمقراطيه وفي الكرامه
بالنسبه
في الزمن الطويل واعتبر ان النظام الشعب
من اجل بناء الدوله المؤسسات ودوله
الديمقراطيه ما زال متواصلا انه صار في
اجهاض الثوره
بالاساس بقرار اقليمي وقرار دولي وضعف همم
الطبقه السياسيه التي انهارت امام يعني
تهديدات صارت عمليه يعني ضرب الثوره
والثوره المضاده التي اخذت همم زمامه
الامور منذ
2014 فشلت تماما في اداره المرحله وهي
الان اخر مراحل فشلها حيثما يشاهده اليوم
الافلاس اقتصادي واجتماعي لمنظومه الثوره
المضاده وظهور الشارع الان من جديد بقوه
ومطالبته برحيل المنقلبي الاخير يدل على
ان الثوره ما زالت متواصله والامل ما زال
موجود وانا دائما وابدا اريد ان ابعثه
حثيثه وروح الامل في في شعبنا انه لا رمى
كل المؤامرات على ثوره ورام اجهاضها ورام
كل مسار مازلنا قائمين وما زلنا واقفين
وانا عندي قناه عن الثوره ستتجدد مسارها
يعني مسار تاريخي طويل المدى الشعوب لا
تتغير يعني هكذا في عشر سنوات هي تحتاج
الى كثير من الوقت الى كثير من التجارب
الى احياننا يعني توقف تراجع لكن هذا هو
المسار الطبيعي وانا فخور بشعبنا اليوم
لانه اظهر انه فعلا الثوره ما زالت حيا ما
زالت موجوده في القلوب والان الان مسؤوليت
كل الاطراف انها تمر الى ما بعد هذا اليوم
يعني هذا اليوم هو منعطف حقيقي صحيح لكن
ما زالت العمليه يعني للتخلص من هذا
النظام البائس وللاعاده قطار الثوره
والديمقراطيه على على
يعني على اساسها الصحيحه هذا مسؤوليه كل
الاطراف وانا ادعو كل الاطراف السياسيه
الان الى التحلي باقصى قدر ممكن من ال-
يعني من المسؤوليه حتى نتخلص من هذا من
هذه الثوره المضاده حتى نعيد بالثوره
والبناء المشروع الثوره اللي هي الدوله
ديمقراطيه شعب المناعه من المواطنين وليس
شعب من الرعايه دوله قانون ومؤسسات في
خدمه هذا الشعب الاستقرار الان
المسؤوليتنا هي يعني مواكبه هذه
يعني هذه الثوره لم تنتهي هم كانوا يحلمون
بان هذه الثوره انتهت والان شعبنا اظهر
للشعب التونسي وللشعوب العربي كلها الثوره
هذه متجدده وباقيه وان شاء الله يعني
ستاتي اكلها زمان او قصر
يعني كانت دائما حينما يتم مقارنه تونس
بدور المشرق العربي ودول الربيع العربي
الاخرى ان تونس مختلفه تونس فيها نقبه
ناضجه نخبه واعيه وفيها شعب متعلم لماذا
لم يكن هذه لم تكن هذه النخبه الناضجه
الواعيه والشعب المتعلم حصنا من ان تسير
تونس في مسار ثوره الربيع العربي الاخرى
التي اتجهت نحو الاستبداد
البلدان العربيه
نفس التنافسات يعني وقعت عليها مؤامره مره
اخرى همم يعني يقول لك انه اجهاض الثوره
الثوره العربيه الربيع العربي كان قرار
اقليمي وكان قرار دولي تضافر مع كل ضعف
الموجود داخل
اتحمل للمسؤوليه في ضعف مواجهه هذا
الفيديو الاقليمي والدولي الذي تعرفه جيدا
حيث القضيه التي تحمل فقط السياسيه واعتبر
السياسيه نحن شعب صغير تاامرت علينا قوه
جباره بالمال فاسد بالاعلام الفاسد الذي
ثوره وتصورت انك القضيه انتهت وان مهد
الثوره العربيه انتهاء كذا كذا فهذا شعب
اظهر له من جديد
لانه هزمنا يعني دائما اقول يعني نحن
خسرنا المعارك لكن سنربح الحرب نحن يعني
شعب تونسي والشعوب العربيه خسرنا معركه ال
10 سنوات الاخيره عندما امرت كل القوات
هذه شهاده الثوره في سوريا مش هاقدر فيه
في في في ليبيا اجهاضها في مصر واجهاتها
في تونس لكن كل هذه الشعوب ستستعيد ثقتها
في نفسها وستعيد الحركيتها وستفرض تحرها
شاء او همم لم تشاء هذه القوه الاقليميه
والدوليه التي تريد الى العراق ان يفقدها
دائما تحت الاستبداد
ستفيد المستقبل ستستعيد لكن لماذا لم
تستعد حتى الان
لم تستعد لحد الان بانه هناك ظروف موضوعيه
حقيقيه لكن بين قوس مره اخرى اريد ان اركز
على قراءه الكاس نصف الكاس الان وانا سمعت
التقرير يركز فقط على نصف الكاس الفئران
نصف كاس الان هو انه اليوم فعلا انه كانت
هناك اربع طباورات لكن هذه الاربعه
تظاهرات متفقه على ثلاثه اشياء متفقه على
انهاء الانقلاب بما معناها العوده الى
الدستور الثوره متفقه ايضا على انه ما
نريده مستقبل هو نظام الديمقراطيه لا نظام
عسكري ولا نظام حكم فردي ومتفق على انه
يجب العوده الى الانتخابات الحره لسياده
الشعب يعني كل هذه الاطراف متفقه ماذا
تريدون اكثر يعني هذه قصه انه المعارضه
كلها يجب ان تكون صفا واحدا وراء شخص واحد
هذا غير موجود في كل البلدان العالم هذا
قبل كنت اعطيته التصريح قلت انا كلمه
مانديلا اعرف ان مانديلا وما ادراك لم
يستطيع ان يحرر افارقه ضد النظام كان هناك
معركه ما بينه وما بين بوت ميسي الى اخر
لحظه صارت فيها دماء يعني تقريبا رغم انه
مانديلا والعظيم مانديلا لم يستطيع ان
يوحد فلماذا تريدون من هذه الاطراف كلها
ان تتحد كلها لا المهم هو انا تتفق على
نهايه الديكتاتوريه وهذا متفقين عليه على
التمسك بدستور الثوره وهذا كل الاطراف
متفقه عليه على الذهاب الانتخابات حره
ونزيه وانا ذاك يتنافس المتنافسون اما هذا
مجيد تحط لي شر تقول لي انا لا استطيع ان
نؤمن الا اذا كان هناك زعيم او احد انتهاء
الذي قصه الزعيم الله احد لا في الحكم ولا
في المعارضه انتهيت هذه قسم الحزب الذي
واحد كل الاطراف الانفاق استراتيجي على
نهايه الاستبداد وعلى الذهاب الى الشعب
الى الانتخابات الحره
هذا هو المطلوب هو نهايه استبدال كما تقول
للمعارضه كما تفضل لكن السبيل الى ذلك هل
السبيل الى ذلك فقط باستمرار التظاهر في
الشارع همم
تدخل من القوه التي تدعم او تخلي من القوه
التي تدعم الرئيس قيس سعيد يعني هنالك في
هذا البرنامج همم في بدايه البرنامج تتحدث
احد الضيوف واتهم
معكم شخصيا بانكم تدعونا الجيش
للاطاحه بالقيس سعيد
انا اولا انا اعول على الشعب الشعب
المواطنين انا ادعو منذ البدايه للشعب
المواطنين انه يمارس يعني بكل قوه ال- ال-
المقاومه المدنيه السلميه كما فعل الشعب
السريلانكي الشعب السريلانكي هو الذي طرد
الديكتاتور
وسبح في يعني في المسبح بتاع القصر انا
ادعوا شعب تونسي مره اخرى الى انه فعلا
ينظم نفسه بكيفيه انه يستطيع بالمقاومه
المدنيه السلميه ان يتخلص من هذا
الديكتاتور يعني
يضعه في السجن لكن ايضا انا طلب فعلا من
من الجيش ومن الامن ومن القضاه ومن
الاعلاميين من كل تونسيين يتحمله
مسؤوليتهم في ايقاف هذه المهزله لانه تونس
مره اخرى كانت مفخره للعرب اصبحت اليوم
مسخره فعلا اصبحت مسخره يعني لو كان حتى
عندنا الديكتاتور مثل السيسي يعني مسخره
يحكومه هذا الرجل طلبت انه الجيش وكل اللي
هو ان تتحمل مسؤوليه في ازاحه هذا الشخص
لانه لم يعد له اي شرعيه لك
هذا الرجل ولم يهاجمه مره واحده لكن لما
انقلب على الدستور اعتبرته راي صغير شرعي
وهو ليس مؤهل لان يعطي اوامر لا للجيش ولا
للامن ولا القضاه القضاه والجيش والامن
وكلهم في حل من اطاعه رجل انقلب على
الدستور وضع يده على القران على المصحف
الشريف وحدث بان يحمي الدستور ونقض وحده
واصبح رئيس غير شرعي اضافه لهذا يذكر بانه
الشعب رفض له في الاستشاره 50% رفضوا
المشاركه بالاستاره 75% رفضوا يعني همم
التصويت على الدستور 90% رفض والانتخابات
اي رسائل اكثر من هذا الجيش
وهذا الرئيس غير شرعي وبالتالي يجب ان
يرحل وكل يوم يبقى في هذا الرجل في السلطه
الا وتزداد الحاله تعفنه وفقر يزداد
والمصائص تزداد
الانقلاب حتى تعود تونسي الحاله الطبيعيه
وحتى يعود الاقتصادي لحالته الطبيعيه
طيب دكتور المصري يعني تقول الجيش يتدخل
اليس هذا القلابان يعني اذا تدخل الجيش في
اي بلد هذا انقلاب ليس نستبدل انقلاب
هو الذي وقع في في تونس عندما حدث هذا
الرجل وعندما كذب على الشعب الذي انتخبه
منه انا حاله بان يحمل دستور فانقلب عليه
اذا هذا الرجل اصبح غير شرعي وبالتالي على
كل القوه التونسيه الشعب المواطنين الذي
ادعوه الى التمسك بالمقاومه المدني
السلميه وايضا انا اقول انا كنت قاعد على
القوات المسلحه وكنت انتظر من الجيش ان
يدعم الثوره والجيش دعم الثوره الشرعيه
تماسات بالشرعيه عندما خسرت الانتخابات
ذهبت في حادث سبيله الى اخره هذا رجل خرج
على الشرعيه
اذا الجيش وكل المؤسسات وشعب المواطنين
هذا الرجل وان يعطى يكون درس لي كل انسان
يريد مره اخرى ان يدخل الديمقراطيه وان
يضرب الديمقراطيه من الداخليه لها اشكرك
شكرا جزيلا من باريس الدكتور المنصف مقيم
الرئيس التونسي الاسبق شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا
نهايته الحصاد هذه